Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to transform ourselves into
cartoon characters. And it is going to be amazing.
But how? Well, for instance, let’s start out
from style transfer. Style transfer means
mixing two images together, one for content,
reimagined with the other one for style. This
also works for video, what’s more, there are also
computer graphics techniques that can update these
virtual worlds in real time as we mark up these
examples on a piece of paper. How cool is that!
That is all well and good, but that’s nothing
compared to what you are going to see today,
because now, we are going to
run style transfer…on ourselves!
That sounds great! But, wait, that’s not
exactly a new idea, previous techniques have
already tried that, so our question is, have
they done it well? Let’s have a look. Oh my,
these are not so good. And even the better ones
are not nearly ready for prime time yet. However,
hold on to your papers because we now have a new
technique, where again, in goes a video of us,
and a target style, and we get…this! Whoa.
These are so much better! So cool! And if
only we could try it ourselves right now…maybe
that is possible, I’ll tell you in a moment.
And it doesn’t stop there, this paper
has a ton more in the tank. For instance,
this slider is incredible, by
using it, we can tell the AI
how much should the style influence the
video. These results are going by quick,
so I’ll stop the process here and there so we can
have a little more time to have a look together.
I particularly liked the fact that we have a
ton of control over the jawline and the eyes,
and of course, if we wish, these features
can get exaggerated a great deal,
or we can be a little more subtle with them. And
everything in between these two are also possible!
And, have a look at this one too, this
is one of my favorite parts of the paper.
Are you seeing it? Well, look here. Our input
person has long hair, but the style reference
has short hair. And I love how the technique
reimagines the input person’s hair as well in the
style of the reference. It doesn’t even break a
sweat. This is such an amazing usability feature.
And it supports a variety of
different styles. Just choose
the movie and the character of your
liking, and there we go. Loving it.
And just think about the fact that a
couple papers before this one, in 2020,
this was possible. Even inpainting real
images of human faces was quite challenging,
and today, just a couple more papers down
the line, and we can do so much better,
with so much more artistic
control, and all this for video.
So, let’s pop the question - how long
do we have to wait for such a result?
And this is where I fell off the chair when
reading the paper. Don’t blink. Why? Because
that’s exactly how long it takes for each
image. We are talking high-resolution images,
and we get 5 to 10 of those
every second. 5 to 10! Wow.
I would absolutely love to see what the amazing
artists among you Fellow Scholars will be able
to do with this. This could make the job of
virtual actors for animation movies easier,
and I bet it will be a super fun tool
for videoconferencing with our friends
and beloved ones, and even putting our copies
into virtual worlds. What a time to be alive!
Now wait, all that is well and good,
but when do we get to use it? Well,
I have two good news for you. Good news number
one, the source code of this project is available,
free of charge for everyone, and good news
number two, as of the making of this video,
you can also try it yourself online. The
links are available in the video description,
and make sure to read the instructions carefully.
Also note that the web app is a bit slower than
running it locally, but of course, it is
so much more convenient for most people.
Now, not even this technique is perfect, as
for almost all DeepFake-related techniques,
teeth are usually a problem. And, oh yes, sure
enough, it is a problem here too. Look. But,
just think about how far we have come in just a
couple papers. And imagine what we will be able
to do a couple more papers down the line.
My goodness! So this was a paper from the
amazing SIGGRAPH ASIA conference, which
is one of the most prestigious venues in
computer graphics research. Having a paper
published there is perhaps equivalent of
the olympic gold medal for a computer graphics
researcher. Huge congratulations to the authors.
So, what do you think? What would you use
this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!